when you write a first draft how
detailed is that first draft how
detailed what do you mean how detailed
and yeah you know I know you talked
about previously off-camera that you
will go back over something fairly soon
but when you're first writing this when
you're creating this world when you're
sitting down how how you know much are
you getting into the details of of the
characters are you really thinking about
their backstory or are you just kind of
like putting out a structure and you
don't outline but of sort of the story
how much are you actually paying
attention to certain things you're just
getting just words out first well it
depends on which script
it depends on this word the story is
coming from generally speaking I don't
have a backstory beyond a sentence or
two okay you know I don't know what they
you know what they were like in sixth
grade or anything like that I just kind
of take from people in real life or
combine people in real life or think of
people I know when I again I just
bounced these characters off each other
knowing that this one is you know sort
of feisty and this one is sort of mellow
and this one is sort of this and then
you can add on the second and the third
adjective sort of as you as you go but I
think in the beginning if I'm going to
introduce a character that I've never in
my life you know I say you know Joe 25
persistent you know I don't know I'll
say two adjectives and then I'll just
move forward that's it it's real real
quick and then I don't necessarily have
to deliver on those adjectives if I feel
like it's going in another direction
maybe he's not persistent
maybe he's maybe he's lackluster maybe
he's lazy I don't know I have to like
write him out a little bit I have to let
him talk in order time to know but the
dynamic between characters is important
in the chemistry so I always start there
that's where I start and the story and
the concept I have as like you know a
sentence
miss Jim what it's not an outline it's
not an it that's not detailed or in
depth the first draft will be detailed
to the absolute to the extent it needs
to be in order to be concise to the
point and not dragging anywhere where we
don't need to be in in particularly in
the action so we enter this room am I
gonna tell you that it's got blue walls
and a couch no because the characters
are what are important and the room is
for the director that's not my job on
the screenwriter that room is for the
director to decide and if you're the
director and the screenwriter great or
whatever but you know people respond to
characters first and foremost and so
that's just really the most detailed
part of my screenplays the action I
would say is the briefest the part of my
scripts
you